You've grown taller, and you're a different person than you were back then.There are
things that have changed and things that haven't changed
.
Talk
Hey, why don't you come to college?
There are people who miss
you when you're not home  Hey,
how's that kid going to college,
so there's no
need to say it?
I'm worried about her future
Right now, even if it's best, I'll limit my remote village to the front and see how much she can grow after that.
Forcing a ship on board Making
it look like I presented a way to make people think that's the only way, I do
n't think we'll change that much
I'll decide,
that child belongs to me. That's what my
intellect
wants.